over the past six months we've been
extremely busy working on improving
Villa's code and today I want to give
you a few highlights and some of the
things we've been working on I want to
talk about our new workspaces
functionality how we made improvements
with the file explorer how we have
improved source control inside the
editor but also some of the more basic
things we have if we have improved such
as layout the text editor itself how
debugging works and how we recommend
extensions to you the first thing I want
to talk about is multi root workspaces
it's been a big feature request to have
supports multiple folders inside vias
code and with multiple multi root
workspaces we enable that I added a link
here to a great article in our
documentation that goes into detail and
how multi would work spaces work but
first let me show you how these things
work so what I have open here is Visual
Studio code with a front-end project
open so what you see here is that I've
opened a folder called time II client
but this is a front-end project that's
also dependent on a back-end project so
before we had multiple multi root folder
workspaces I would need to have two
instances of Visual Studio code open but
what I can do now is that I can go up
here in file and say at folder to
workspace and what are they can do is
that I can select my tiny API project
and I can say add what you now see here
is that I have two folders open inside
Visual Studio and you also see that that
Visual Studio code says I have an
untitled workspace open so this is
pretty cool because now I'm able to work
both on my client side code and my
back-end code at the same time so if I
want to save this workspace let's say
this is this is kind of how I won't work
in the future I can go up here at file
in file and say save workspace as and I
can give it a name so now I saved my
workspace and it's called time II the
cool thing about a workspace is that I
can add a bunch of folders but I can
also add a bunch of settings so if I
open my command palette here in the vias
code I can basically say choose the
option open workspace settings and what
are you seeing now
here is that I have all my settings I
can configure but I can all when I say a
change a setting here I want to save
this setting let's say I want to change
the font size what you now see is that
the setting here is being saved to my
workspace settings and not to my user
settings on my global settings this
basically means that I can share
settings with my team as a part of my
workspace which is pretty cool so you
might wonder like how does his
workspaces work is it like a special
convention or what's going on behind the
scenes and I can just open the command
palette here again and then that can
open workspace configuration file what
you see here is that we just open time
it vs - workspace and this shows a
little JSON file
that shows you the structure and you can
see this just my folders that is a part
of my workspace and my settings this alt
means because it's just a flat file on
your file system is that you can basic
check this file in to your source tree
and share it with your team so that was
workspaces a nifty feature we hope many
of you will find useful the next thing I
want to show you is some of the things
you'll be doing with source control
status in our file explorer let me show
you that so what I have open here in the
US code is my front-end project time II
client and if I for example make a
change here to app that J s let's just
make a change let me scroll up to the
top here and modify like an object and
what you see here is that because I made
a change is that V s code has now picked
up this change and app.js is now shown
in yellow if I hover over the file you
can kind of see that it shows you the
file name but it also shows the status
of this file is modified so what we show
here is little M icon you will also
notice that the folder that app.js is
within has also turned yellow and the
time it find root folders also turned
yellow and what I then can do here for
example if I add a new file so let me
create new j/s once I've saved this file
you'll see that will also show you new
files will highlight new files as
and if you hover over this file it shows
that it's untracked so we show a you
this is a really neat features for
quickly providing you an overview of the
file changes you make and and that way
then you can kind of see if you're
adding editing too many files and you
need to like make commits more often
some of you might might find all this
coloring and icons annoying and so we've
also added a bunch of settings that
enables you to disable all these things
as we enable them by default so if you
go to your settings you can basically
search for Explorer but bigger raters
and what you see here is that we have
two new settings a explore the
decorators that batches if I set this to
false you will basically see all the
batches in the file explorer is now
disappearing we also have explore that
decorators the colors and if I set this
to false you'll see all the color going
away in the file explorer and then
things were as a word before let me just
remove these because I actually like
these colors and so we really hope that
this little feature will help you to
have a better overview of what's going
on when you change files on source
control has also been working on adding
inline controls and inline dips for
source control here's a demo of that so
what I have open here is my app J's as
before and you can kind of see that the
change I made before is it's already
here and you can see that it's
highlighted out here with blue in the
gutter because I modified this file but
let me go to the bottom of this file and
make some more changes let me add some
white spaces here what you see is that
we highlight like new additions as green
and the cool thing we have added for the
vias code is basically inline diffs so
if you hover over the status icon out
here in the gutter and you can now click
on it and what will happen is that we
will open an inline
diff editor that will show you your
change so as you can see here this shows
me the difference between what it where
I had before what I have now and what I
can do is at home this actually looks
pretty good
so let me stage this change now you see
vias code is jumping to the bottom of
the file with my new lines I just
and you know what like I really don't
want like these new lines here so I can
revert these changes and here I'll just
confirm that I don't want these things
anymore and bam and if I now go to the
source control part of Mia's code you'll
see that the changes I just approved
before it's now staged and are ready to
be committed we think this is a really
powerful feature that enables you to do
smaller commits and get a better
overview of the changes you make and it
hopefully makes it much easier for you
to make the right commits at the right
time on source control we have also
added support for multiple source
systems at the same time and and here's
a demo of it so what I have open here is
still my multi wood workspace timing
with my back in project and my front end
project and I'm here in in the source
control part of Visual Studio code if
you look at the top here what you see is
that there's a panel here called source
control providers and you'll see I have
my tiny client that is using git you
also see that I have my tiny API that is
using git and you see the changes that
are just made to my front-end project
the cool thing is is that we now support
multiple of these providers so if I
click on thaimee API I will now see that
I don't have any changes in my API and
that way then I can actually jump
between source control providers from
workspace folder to workspace folder the
more interesting thing is that both my
projects in this example is using git
but if I've assembled where to use SVN a
team validation system or anything like
that I can actually just click this menu
here and choose to install additional
source providers right away
and this basically means that you can
use get and SVN at the same time B as
code supports it on the more basic
front-end code we have also been adding
support for virtual docking for panels
and here's how this works
so what I have open here is my app J's
as before in my client side project the
first thing I want to do here is that I
want to show you the integrated terminal
we have in vs code so I just say view
integrate a terminal but you know what
like I'm usually I'm on
large screen that is in a widescreen
format so having my chairman at the
bottom of the screen it's not really
using my my screen very well so we have
added vertical docking and if you look
here to the right we have a new icon
called move to right so if I click this
icon you'll see that we move all the
panels including the terminal to the
right and there's just a little feature
that enables you to take better
advantage of you having a larger screen
and hopefully it enables you to be more
productive on the editor front we have
been adding support for code region
folding and here's how it works for
JavaScript so I still have my client
side project open and I have AB jeaious
I have a PS open what you see in envious
code is that if you have a function that
we already support code folding that you
can basically fold in or collapse a
function but we also add a support for
custom regions so this is basically
supporting what a lot of programming
language is already supported you can
make a comment and you can use the hash
and you can add a region so I can add a
region here called Kenneth and I can in
this region in a piece of Coast by
saying end region what you now see is
that vias code is now able to fold this
region and collapse this and this is an
example into in JavaScript but
out-of-the-box we support region folding
for go Python and a bunch of other
programming languages and if there's a
programming language that we don't we
don't support yet please open issue and
github so we can get it working
we've also added support for automatic
imports for JavaScript and typescript
and here's a cool demo of this so what I
have open here is still my front end
project in Visual Studio code and what
I've opened is my places component
places at Jas in this particular
component I want to use some date
formatting logic so let me show you how
that works so here how to say is date
and what you see here from the
autocomplete er is that we have
automatically detected a moment Jas so
we can actually automatically import
this reference for you so if I press
ENTER here what you see is that his date
was automatically imported from
moment.js here in the top so
this way then you can kind of explore
your your JavaScript code and without
having to all do to do all these import
statements by yourself you can also add
some of that to your editor on the
refactoring side we have added support
for method extracting both the
JavaScript in typescript and here's how
this works so I still have my front-end
project open here in Visual Studio code
and to show you how method extracting
works I will open up my my place
component I use to render my application
in this component I have a get in
activity information method that does a
lot of things and some of the things
that is doing is trying to generate the
righteous S Class for a particular time
of day but you know what like this this
logic here could be quite useful to have
in kind of a utility function so what I
can do here is that I can select my code
and you'll see that this little light
bulb is appearing it's called show fixes
so if I click it it will basically
people some suggestions on what to do
and one of them here is that I can
extract this this logic to a method in
in in in the place class so I select
this and then it asked me for a name I
would like to call this get CSS class
and I press Enter what you now see is
that my code has been refactored to use
this method I just introduced and the
logic I was highlighted before has
automatically been extracted into a new
function for debugging we have added
something called composite debugging
that enable enables you to debug
multiple things at the same time and I'm
gonna show you how this works now we
should show you a code or have a great
debugger that enables you to debug
JavaScript in node but also in the
browser with Chrome we also support
debugging Go Python a lot of other
programming languages but for the
example I'm using javascript so if I
open up my launch to Jason that is a
configuration file for how you configure
the debugger then you see I have a
configuration for how to do no js'
debugging and how to do chrome debugging
and the new thing we have added is
something we call compounds that enable
you to make configurations that is using
other debug
figurations so in this particular case I
made a compound called full stack that
is using both my node and chrome
debugger and to give you a demo of how
this works let me first go into the
terminal here and start my my API so I
just went into my API folder and let me
start it up so now my API is running a
localhost / 3001 what I can do is that I
can go to the debugging is section of
Thea's code and I can select the full
stack configuration what you now see
vias code is doing that is styling an
instance of Chrome and it's asking me
what node process to connect to let me
select my API what you now see is that
with one click I both launch Chrome and
connect it Visual Studio code to my
chrome instance and you and you also see
that my node debugger has been started
so this means at this point in time vs
code can keep up both your front end and
your back end at the same time this is
just a demo what you can do with
JavaScript you can also imagine that you
want to debug your two different
back-end systems as using coordinate or
or Python and you can do that with
compounds we think compounds are really
powerful and so we can't wait to see
what you do with them for debugging we
have also added support for line numbers
and sources inside the debug and console
here's how this looks so what I have
open here is vias code already connected
to to Chrome as I showed you before and
if you notice down here in the debug
console and we now show line numbers and
the source of of a console that log
statement so my application has emitted
place in Seattle what you can see here
is that this is coming from places J is
line 63 if I click on this will take you
to the Huayra line where this console
dot log messages and the cool thing
about this is that this console that log
statement is coming from places rj s but
that's not what the browser is see the
browser is seeing a bundled deepak
minified file but it will pass a source
map for you and show you the right place
and we think that's pretty cool and
we've also been adding coloring it
inside the debugging console so you can
use console
locks and errors and other things here's
how this looks so here have Visual
Studio code still connected to my chrome
instance what you probably already have
noticed on the console is that we have
this red statement called not an error
and that's basically like it's just a
console that error that's been outputted
for my application but what's new in
code is that will actually colorize it
so for red we for errors we show a color
red so this is a quick way for you to
distinguish between errors and just
regular control that locks and for
extensions we've been working on
improving the extensions would recommend
to you because we think they're they're
vital to how you use vs code I still
have my workspace open with my back end
and a front-end project but what I can
do here is that if I go to the
extensions part of these code you see
down here at the bottom that we have
this new recommended section and like
there's a bunch of different extensions
here that has a little style because
they recommend to me so if I choose from
this beautify extension you can see that
this has been this extension is
recommended based on the file system
or the files you open recently so this
basically means that we have figured out
hey you open JavaScript quite often so
maybe this extension makes make sense
for you another recommendation we have
here is for example the darker extension
for vias code and this extension is
recommended to me because I already have
dogger installed on my computer so with
this and these improved recommendations
we're trying to be a bit more
intelligent about how extensions work in
vias code so we can give you the right
tools and in the right support for the
workflows that you have so that was the
highlights I want to show you today but
as next steps I I want to recommend you
to download the villa's code inside
edition that basic gives you the latest
bits as we're shipping everyday
and by that you also get a chance to
help us providing feedback before
features hit the market and if you kind
of cues to know more about the features
I talked about and what else we've been
up to I can highly recommend go to code
that Visual Studio comm to read more and
lastly I want you to revisit all the
videos from connectors
already on channel 9 and especially was
the keynote where we talked about
something called live share that enables
you to do collaborative editing but also
collaborative debugging thanks